the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
one fight night 10. Johnson versus
Marias three on Prime video
them giving the shot to Kobe I think it
like worked out better for me because
that's when the fans started to be like
all right well bro that doesn't make any
sense at all this guy's on 85 winning
streak he has history with Leon you know
what else does he need to do so it's
cool to see those fans even the haters
that were coming alive like I was like
getting so many messages like I hate you
but
no Brandon
what's up fam Monday April 24th what is
popping how's everybody doing everyone's
good great grand wonderful
I'm busy busy weekend of fights in the
fight game from the biggest boxing fight
of the Year hopefully it's not the
biggest hopefully get another big
announcement maybe with our boy Francis
a little Wilder action but either way
huge fight between Javonte Davis Ryan
Garcia and then you had our boy Curtis
blades ended up on the short end of the
Russian stick against Sergey pavlovich
which was a tough night in the office
for Curtis blades it's hard
heartbreaking for him
um you just got Tucker Carlson left Fox
and you got Don Lemon left so the world
is going mad the world is going mad did
you know that Jen no my brother just
texted me he's like I don't know what's
going on Don Lemon just got fired at uh
CNN that was kind of coming though yeah
he spit a few mistakes right I can't
even last that long and then Tucker
Carlson I decided guest he decided to
part ways with Fox that's dope though do
his own thing that's why he's even on
his own thing they should do a first
take kind of Tucker Carlson Don Lemon
First Take type of vibe no one get a
word out they just argue the whole time
I'd be lit though like breaking points
you know you know the left and right
they do the thing that'd be yeah I don't
know if people tune in there's so much
hatred for both of those men but we'll
see uh either way so the world's on fire
so that's cool
um yeah so let's get right into it the
biggest event over the weekend
Curtis blades I'm sorry Javonte Davis
um Ryan Garcia
um man what uh an event
um what a fight if you guys were
watching the entire card like your boy
did
um you saw a huge Rising Prospect in
David Morrell just that Savage that just
absolutely murked that poor gentleman
who was a bronze medalist who took the
final like 10-day notice
um you know that's part of the problem
with boxing is the undercards but that
Dave Morell is one to keep an eye on uh
outside that though Devonte Davis Ryan
Garcia
um you know Javonte Davis was a favorite
for a reason
um but before we get into the technical
aspect of the fight and how Ryan lost
and we go down that road you know you
got to take your hat off to both Devonta
Davis and Ryan Garcia because the number
one problem in boxing is the the
business model of box and with so many
promoters so many mouths to get fed is
we don't get the fights that we want
when they should happen it's always been
the number one problem in boxing since
I've been alive it's one of the reasons
might be the biggest reason the UFC has
totally taken over the Combat Sports
space because we know in the UFC you're
going to get the young Prospect who's
undefeated against the other young
Prospect undefeated you're eventually
get that fight it's not going to take
years you're gonna get in a few months
that's why the UFC destroys any other
competition especially in boxing not
only going to get that but the cards can
be stacked with other uh Blue Chip you
know kind of guys other big prospects
other big names that you know know the
entire card from top to bottom
especially the main cards are stacked
boxing even this fight card being
massive you know with Javonte Davis
Garcia the card wasn't great like you
couldn't wait for that main event to
start that's the other problem with
boxing but again this all goes back to
we need to take our hats off no matter I
don't care if Ryan got knocked out in 10
seconds I don't care if Devonte Davis
got knocked out in the third round I'm
not too concerned about the result of
the fight but you need to acknowledge
that Ryan Garcia and Javonte Davis who
are you know from a younger generation
they don't subscribe to the old box in
ways where we don't get the fights we
want to see there you know there's all
these weird stipulations there's all
these contract negotiations these two
gentlemen wanted this fight even despite
their teams going ah it's gonna be tough
or for whatever reason there's no belts
on the line decide to add a catch weight
and they made the fight happen which is
in today's world in boxing is insane so
both these guys finally gave us what we
wanted and uh you know
I don't I don't know if you'd say it's
the exact fight you thought you were
gonna get
um and you know I uh
tweeted this right after the fight
um just watching Ryan and
um my experience in Combat Sports
when you get hit to the body you know it
sucks at first you'd rather get hit in
the head for God's sakes but when you
get uh hit to the body you know there's
a delay so you can see the delay set in
on Ryan Garcia and then he takes a knee
but especially with Ryan's uh pedigree
especially with his experience you know
it's just a matter of time before that
pain goes away and you're back in the
fight so I thought but him taking knee
that's normal everyone you hit the body
especially in boxing taking the recover
you're gonna make the count and you get
back up and you have a little time to
navigate then you use footwork to uh
negotiate the pain away until it
completely goes away then you can go
back to your game plan so when I saw him
not answer the Bell not answer the the
standing eight count and and I'm like oh
something's going on there he had to
been hurt because
guarantee you he's ever ever uh he's
been hit there many times you can take
that down too he's been hit many times
before many many times before and I
guarantee you got back up but with this
that's why I alluded to oh he came and
injured now that doesn't mean he was
going to win the fight that doesn't mean
that you know when he got dropped in the
second round that had anything to do
with it all I'm saying is I bet if Ryan
didn't have a body injury a rib injury
going into that fight we would have got
more rounds I'm not saying he would have
won the fight you know and for the
people like oh you know I would have got
up off that body shot really how many
times you've been hit to the body you
know so I'm not making any excuse for
Ryan all I'm saying is it's a shame he
had that injury going into the fight
because we would have saw more rounds it
was not looking great for him you know
his his left hook was completely
isolated Javonte Dave's team did a
ridiculous job just kind of negating
that left hand so his hook his biggest
weapon you really didn't see it at all
he might have landed a counter
um his jab you know was probably his
best weapon throughout the fight outside
that you know Ryan Garcia had his hands
full and Javonte Davis is known you know
to kind of he's a slower starter where
he downloads the data and then goes to
work similar to Floyd Mayweather
differences he knocks guys out so the
javonta Davis even though he knocked him
out in that second or knocked him down
that second round that was due to Ryan
Garcia being so aggressive I think the
the moment you know Javonte Davis has
been in those big Pay-Per-View fights
Ryan Garcia he's been in big fights
because he's Ryan Garcia he's never been
a fight of this magnitude and I thought
his inexperience kind of got he had a
little over uh kind of not maybe excited
he had a little overzealous he he was
too excited in the moment thought I was
gonna get Devonte Davis out there when
he Landings and when that happened
that's when you know he got knocked down
the second round and then in that
seventh round which Devonte Davis
predicted uh he put him down that body
shot again that fight was not going
Ryan's way I thought it could give him
maybe two to three rounds three being
super generous going to that seventh
um so the fight was definitely not going
his way all I'm saying is for a guy of
Ryan Garcia's caliber to not answer the
count off a body shot there would have
to be something going on outside of the
Ring going into the fight that's it you
know what's weird we got so much
blowback from that oh blah blah blah
blah blah weird and then his training
partner gets on there and goes yeah I
heard him to the body
in practice you know ongoing kid Urban
tar a lightweight Prospect uh post this
Ryan Garcia confirms he had a mole in
his Camp before the Javonte Davis fight
after 5-0 Mongolian spawn partner
you guys know his name's Jimmy tough uh
speaks out about hurting him to the body
and sparring something Javonte Davis
knew about the fight now I did see this
kid to defend this uh sparring part of
his goes I'm not the mole yeah he's and
but he I guess he said he was using some
sort of translation he was you know
English of my first language I'm not
saying I was the mole and ratted to
Javonte Davis I'm just saying one of the
reasons he didn't answer the count is
because he was hurt that's all he's
saying no that's I think Ryan was saying
like Okay how would people know about
this unless there was a mole yeah and I
think he's he's the guy that yeah and he
thought maybe Ryan was alluding to him
but I don't that's not what rhymes and
Ryan also was like that's not why I lost
the fight it just sucked we have a mole
in the camp yep you know so my whole
thing there that's it's not again I said
this it's not taking anything away from
tank Davis he's he was the better boxer
you know and right now until Ryan get
some more experience under his belt in
those bigger fights it's gonna be a
tough night in the office to beat tank
Davis Ryan had his moments but overall
Davis was doing very well handling the
fight for the majority of the rounds
even dropped him you know and shout out
to Ryan for taking that punching him
back up because tank hits like an
absolute [__] Mack truck got up like
that too yeah so
um you know I I all I'm alluding to is
Ryan Garcia at the caliber and he's been
boxing since he was seven he's been hit
to the body he knows how to navigate
that pain and get back to his feet for
him not to do that in the biggest
Fighter's life yeah sir
I've been there yeah
yep I was like oh oh man he's like oh
he's hurt he was like oh you're making
excuses no anything I've never said he
was going to win the fight I'm just
saying if he wasn't hurt you would have
got more rounds now would he been
stopped in the 8th 9th 10th probably the
way that fight was going and the way we
know tank gets better as the rounds go
on yeah it would have probably gotten
worse for Ryan to be honest you know but
again I don't care too much about the
outcome of this fight what we you need
to make note of is Ryan think about all
the [__] going on with boxing right
now with Tyson Fury usik uh uh Crawford
Earl Spence Jr how how many times have
we heard Earl Spence and Crawford are
going to fight last four years probably
three three legit three years we've been
promised that fight every year why do
you think that's not happening
now Devonte Davis Camp Ryan Garcia's
Camp even they're like the promoters
like yeah we don't know we're not with
Showtime we have to kind of you know
bend the knee to him Brian's like yeah
cool then with tank you know they're
like man let's go for somebody else it
was probably easy for a Showtime put
this on you know with the the team Money
Mayweather [__] all that it'd probably
be easier if we go with this opponent
and tank goes nope I want Ryan Ryan goes
nope I want tank get it done ah but you
gotta do this you know you can only meet
them at a certain weight and it's gonna
catch weight and there's no titles
online they don't care these young kids
do not care it's kudos to them and these
old heads with Tyson Fury usick Joshua
uh you know anybody name any fighter out
there Earl Spencer Terence Crawford take
freaking notes man
look how big of the ones last time you
saw that big of a fight in boxing and
just the atmosphere it was insane dude
win lose or draw what these guys did is
exactly what boxing needs to even
compete with UFC UFC knocks out matchups
and they have way more stars they knock
them out every month damn it every week
boom what do you want yep boom boom boom
you know it's the number one problem in
boxing number one prom but these you
should really no matter how you feel
about the outcome of the fight really
tip your hat to both these gentlemen for
getting it done amazing amazing Fight
Card amazing amazing just event overall
ridiculous
you know it sucks Ryan's my boy and you
know I want him to win but at the end of
the day I you know there's a reason he
was such a big dog there's a reason and
also with the weight cutting he couldn't
rehydrate like I'm sure that had an
effect on him going in injured you know
it's a tough gig against Devonte Davis
who you know is right now the face of
boxing and for you know only being 100
36 pounds which he's even lighter than
that but uh fight 136 pounds to be that
much of a knockout artist is insane 28
known 26 Knockouts is silliness
face Suboxone man and do it in his
outfit
his his robe the human-made robe and
then he had the the I think they're the
skunks uh the Nike Dunk skunks on that
they converted into boxing shoes dude
filthy and then Ryan Garcia looked dope
too
but that that's what you want man that's
what you want I thought I thought it was
great I there's really nothing like a
big boxing fight of that caliber just
the atmosphere the vibe like damn this
is great everyone was out there you
almost forgot y'all must have forgot but
we did how could we remember boxing
doesn't give us this ever ever
ever look Tyson Fury is Unified homeboy
who's it now no no that Ruiz oh okay
okay it's not but who seeks the champ
here's all the belts okay
if I find any rules I guess
Anthony Joshua Tyson Fury biggest fight
in UK London history make that happen no
don't get it
uh Crawford Spence let's see who's path
around and when no that happened
it's insane it's nuts so it's the number
one problem then you'll see dangerous
announcing all sorts of fights some
you're like hmm right something like all
right but overall the point is they
dropped some bombs dude they got blue
Mohammed
Gilbert Burns co-headlining UFC 288 May
6th we're doing a fight companion for
that but uh Muhammad is on the episode
today he's sitting down with uh Muhammad
he's calling in
um interested to talk with him he's one
of my faves and what's interesting about
Gilbert Burns and Muhammad also Gilbert
burns the Run he's on three fights this
year not and before that his fight with
hamzat which I think was the most
impressive thing he's done even out of
all his wins like what do you do with
Hamza it's nutsos so he's fought those
four fights three three three and one
out of the four fights
fighting back to back right was he
taking two weeks off now he's finding
below Muhammad Muhammad wins what's that
10 in a row
so where the issue comes I'm going to
talk to Muhammad about this where the
issue comes is if believed Mohammed were
to win this fight that'd be 10 in a row
right
one two three four five six seven eight
so it'd be nine so nine in a row you've
beat everybody
um I just don't get where the argument
is for Colby Compton I'm a Kobe fan I
love Kobe he's a good dude but I just
don't see how after beating Gilbert
Burns if he were to get it done how you
cannot give him the title shot
but Dana's pretty adamant on Colby
firstly on Edwards so if you're
believing Mohammed or Gilbert Burns
whoever wins this fight I just don't see
how the UFC is not going to go uh let's
give you one more there's no way there's
no way literally you can't it's like no
the winner of this is getting the Top
Shot guarantee it I have to and if they
are gonna carry on with Leon Edwards and
Colby Covington these boys are probably
sitting out what because Leon Edwards
and Colby Leon say he's not fighting on
the the pay-per-view in uh London that's
not happening so announce a fight night
so you're looking at Leanna was fighting
late this year
so if he fights late this year against
Colby if you're the Muhammad or your
um Gilbert Burns you're looking at fine
early quarter one 2024. that ain't right
isn't that [__] up
now luckily Gilbert got his working you
know he could use a bit of a rest not a
year though you know
yeah that that May 6 card is tasty bro
super tasty let me see the lineup chin
yeah because you you uh 288 then we're
gonna have uh Charles Olivera right
Charles Olivera and uh they got hurt so
they're like all right say this you got
Al Jermaine Sterling Henry sahudo fire
uh Muhammad Gilbert Burns which is five
rounds mind you which I love when they
do this when even though it's not for a
title Dana's like well this is such a
big fight we're gonna make it five
rounds I think you should do that more
often
um Jessica Andres Young
uh most of our Bryce Mitchell Crown Drew
Dober
yeah
it's a tasty main card
I'm excited for it
um yeah but shout out to Blue Muhammad
who will be on the show a little bit uh
and then also shout out to Ryan Garcia
and tank Davis for getting it freaking
done and saving boxing right now God how
many chains did Floyd Mayweather have on
I don't know how do you put him on it
must take 30 minutes to take those off
I'd be scared to wear them he has
security everywhere but it also has to
be uncomfortable I know it's got to be
heavy as [__] my God it looked so
uncomfortable he looks sweet but not for
me man
I mean I I don't know how much money
that is in Chains
insane insane
insane man let's take a little break
from chatting all the big fight talk
because it's NBA playoffs time that
means big Hoops action with DraftKings
Sportsbook and official sports betting
part of the NBA get in on the excitement
of every game with a touch of a button
new customers can make a five dollar
pregame moneyline bet and score 150 and
bonus bets if your team wins plus
everyone can score a no sweat same game
parlay every day during the NBA Playoffs
open the DraftKings Sportsbook app
opt-in and plays the same game parlay on
any NBA game if it doesn't hit you'll
get a bonus bet back up to ten dollars
my nuggets they should have won last
night went to overtime even though they
were down 10 with like three minutes
left went to overtime they lost not a
big deal the series is what three to one
now they're gonna blow them out this
next game put your money on my nuggets
you can also bet on the Lakers they're
owning Memphis right now uh the Knicks
should get it done as well
um who else she got popping
um oh golden State Not a Bad Bet
especially with that home game five
they're definitely try winning that one
they did start out the series uh O2 and
I think it's tied up 2-2 so Golden
State's not a bad bet there's a lot of
action going on but bet on my nuggets
get done in the west also bet on Golden
State to get it done as well they ain't
going out like that download the app
right now sign up with the code shop
show new customers can make a five
dollar pregame money line bet and score
150 in bonus bets if your team wins only
at DraftKings Sportsbook with the code
shops show schab show gambling problem
call Wayne Hunter Gambler in
Massachusetts call
800-327-5050 or visit gambling
helplinema.org in New York call 8778
Hope and why or text Hope NY that's
467-369 in Kansas call win
100-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino Resort Kansas 21 or older most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details in state specific responsible
gambling resources
Seashore notes for details DraftKings
this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by the best Kratom on the
planet it's one that I recommend because
I use everyday most products oh damn
near every product that you recommend
that I recommend every single show I do
I'm personally endorsing and that I
actually use the products I reach out to
happy hippo to be part of all my shows
because I love happy hippo Kratom this
stuff helps me tackle my insane schedule
it helps me get stuff done sometimes my
brain just ain't working like it should
listen it's not like uh if you drink
like a lot of caffeine or something like
that you're talking about it gives you a
warm ready to go balance good mood
feeling to tackle whatever the day
throws at you I my favorite are the
instant shots here this is the sour
apple which I start out with they have
butterscotch they have gummies powders
whatever pills anything you want it's
the best great it's the only tradem that
I trust out there in this wild wild west
Kratom game it's the number one Kratom
on the planet for a reason that's Happy
Hippo their Kratom is a Hidden Gem so
get it on the action go to happy hippo
promo code is thick with three C's
t-h-i-c-c-c 23 for 20 off the entire
site you can use that as many times you
want share with your friends your family
co-workers whoever's listening this you
want to try out create them only try out
happy hippo it's the only one I
recommend that's Happy hippo.com promo
code thick 23 20 off let's get back to
the program uh and another fight over
the weekend you had the Sergey pavlovich
versus Curtis blades
uh tell me if I'm off on this you know
I'm a big Curtis blade fan trains with
my old team we've had Curtis on food
truck die he's loved Curtis blades
he's always just come up short right
before he's getting a title shot right
he's like right at the cusp he's either
number four or number three maybe even
up to number two and then right at the
cusp boom loses
by KO
Francis Derek Lewis then Sergey
ain't that a bit
yeah and they're all like Strikers all
the street Strikers he didn't even well
he he attempted a double leg but Sergey
stopped it with his crazy ass Russian
hips it was even close but he also
didn't set up it also looked like
again and I don't know Curtis that well
to sit to but I'm just going off what I
see he didn't look like you he was in
the moment like if something looked off
am I right about that too he even he his
like I don't know his beard wasn't
tailored like he usually is he like
sharpened yeah he just looked off like
his striking was in his Chris maybe it's
the power of Sergey when he because he
Curtis at one point covers up and gets
hit and you see him go and he's like
holy shnikes you know it just didn't
look like your typical Curtis blades
like uh obviously the Tom astronaut one
that was just an injury but the Chris
Dukakis the rosenstruke uh the volkov
fight the Junior dos Santos especially
um it just didn't look the Alistair
Overeem one the mark hunt the Olynyk all
those that didn't look like the usual
cursed blades were used to seeing
especially that man through a fight I
thought it was very strange such a
bummer he's such a good dude I think he
matches up well against Jon Jones but
for whatever reason he gets to the tip
of the mountain and all you got to do is
get a little higher and he it just
hasn't worked out for him it's such a
bummer but he's still he he still
especially in the heavy division
everyone's older he can still do work
there it's not over for me still be a
champ you know this is just another
bump in the road you know but for Sergey
pavlach who hasn't lost since he fought
[__] Alistair over and Alistair beat
the brakes off of him which is hilarious
uh that's a good alistairs he lost uh in
2018. so he lost five years ago
downstairs over him in China
yeah I also really put it on them but
after that it's been Sizzler Russian
Sizzler I mean he's just starching boys
that's uh oh my God look at this dude's
freaking record since he's been the UFC
so in the UFC he lost his first fight
not the way he wants to start but South
Wolverine they'll they're obviously high
on them if the master over him they knew
they had something special so first of
all I asked her over him inside a
nightmare I'll get after that he's never
had a fight in the UFC that didn't
result in a KO
he's one two three four five six that's
six in a row that's a record
he hits so hard and then his hips when
Chris bleach on that double my God those
heavy Russian hips dude my God he was
not having any of it
and the thing too you look at him he's
not fat that boy gots obliques six packs
big ass Russian hands them freaking
Russian nuclear bombs for hands that boy
is a problem now of course everyone's
high and mighty on the on the Russian
right now and he's gonna do his thing
but when they're like man this guy's
gonna beat Jon Jones like Tay and whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa take it easy take it
easy you could you know if he lands one
of those freaking nuclear bombs he's
dropping every fight but uh Jones a
different different pedigree than the
rest of the guys that he's fighting you
know
I think I think Jones would be a
favorite against him uh obviously he
lands one is gonna be an issue but how
about him versus Francis dude
some African Russian crime sign me up
dude that poster would be insane that's
if I would love to see but you're never
gonna get it but uh I think his toughest
matchup for Sergey and I do think this
is what's next for him is surrogon I
think he's as toughest matchup by far
because Sergeant has the ability if he
fights smart to beat him via decision
with his footwork his length his agility
his athleticism he has a lot of tools to
beat a big puncher he really does and it
won't be exciting but he'll beat him in
five rounds he I think you'd be a slight
Doggie in seragon so I I do think that's
what's next for him because you got
Steve A Jones fighting he's not going to
wait sir gone needs a fight Sergey is
number three sir guns right there
they've never fought two Strikers he
passes that test then it's Jon Jones
question is does Jon Jones wait around
to fight a guy in Sergey who's not a
huge name we know him right we know him
because we you know balls deep in MMA
but in general the fan base it's not
gonna be a huge pay-per-view it's all me
predicated on Jon Jones selling this
thing so is Jon Jones going to entertain
that how many fights does John have left
you know because it's the there's the
steepe fight which we're gonna get then
after that is in a brock is it do they
get Francis back is that all he wants
are these massive fights he wants the
toughest test and the biggest Contender
it'd be Sergey more so than Francis more
so than Sarah gone more so than Stipe
the toughest fight on the roster hands
down after watching tape would be Sergey
I just don't know if that gets John out
of bed even though he's this terrifying
Russian like Drago from [__] Rocky
III you know I just don't know if John's
gonna play that game how long he wants
to be around be fun to watch though
Manny hits hard my God
oh man
um you got some fights this weekend uh
for the rest I mean the Bobby green
Jared Gordon my boy Jerry Gordon can't
get a break so he gets screwed over by
the judges against Patty pimlet like
we're gonna give you a big fight main
card fight night at the Apex I'm kind of
sick with Apex but at the Apex here's
Bobby green
and then Bobby green not you know he
didn't mean to but South Paul
Traditional stances happens you gotta be
careful headbutts Bobby green leads with
his head knocks him out
it's a no contest so there's I guess
they rebooked this my boy can't get a
breakdown man it's a bummer
uh Bruno Silva look phenomenal against
Brad Tavares
um you know overall good night of fights
Montel Jackson's gonna be a prom at
bantamweight he's giant that ranaya just
was not ready to go for that old school
super old school
he treated him like he was old school
um this weekend you got uh not this
weekend May 5th you have in Broomfield
Colorado Denver Colorado but it's
Broomfield was about 30 minutes outside
of Denver at the First Bank Arena where
your boy had his first MMA fight with
ring of fire I fought my entire uh
kind of outside the regional circuit was
at the U.S Bank Center so I thought
there four times three times four times
before I was in the UFC uh so it's my
home base and uh that's where one
Championship is coming it's gonna be on
live on Amazon that's Friday night May
5th Cinco de Mayo my girl's b day I will
be in Denver for the fights flying out
you'll see my ugly mug out there on the
TV maybe but that is uh the one
championship fight night 10 and man
they're they're coming big time one
breaks ground the US for its debut event
in Colorado the MMA Mecca that's right
you'll see start in Denver Colorado in
1993. all right
um but you got the trilogy fight between
the goat Mighty Mouse versus Marias and
uh they each have a win over each other
first one was a neem rice need uh Mighty
Mouse on the ground it kind of looked
like my mouse was playing the old school
rules and didn't realize you could knead
of the face to a down opponent so he
lost out one and then Mighty Mouse in
the rematch shout out to him in the
rematch knocks out Marias with a knee so
neon knee action here third fight it's
also
it's not like either guy dominated the
in their first two fights like it's back
and forth like in the one uh Mariah's
one Johnson had his moments in this last
one where Mighty Mouse won Moriah said
his moments I get it's a gimme fight man
so I'm excited for this here's the other
thing you ought to think about
Mighty Mouse who
across the board is going to be on
people's list of Grace of all time you
know it doesn't really matter because
it's all hypothetical because there's no
actual list there's no way to prove it
but Mighty Mouse no matter if he's not
top three on your list you ain't [__]
right so for Mighty Mouse he's talked
about this could be his last fight
the grace of all time at his age he's
not that old especially for a flyweight
but at his age this could be the last
time you ever see him Grace uh the the
the steel cage almost said the outcome
but it's not Afghan is it so
um this is one for history man it's the
one of the biggest trilogies Mighty
Mouse and he did
um kind of the villain and even though
Mariah's a great guy you know Mighty
Mouse is beloved by everybody across the
entire fan base so it just for Mariah's
the way he finished Mighty Mouse that
first fight title fight uh he became the
villain so it's exactly what Demetrius
Johnson needed I'm all about guys
retiring early and this would be a
little easy for Mighty Mouse even though
she had a storied career has so many
fights but after he if he can get past
Marias for this Trilogy fight I don't
know what else there's left for him to
do in the sport he's one of the grace
off time Marias would be world champion
in any organization he's such a Savage
he changed you you didn't come with me
to the press conference he's massive he
he's so big really massive he looks big
next dude massive massive Talent so for
DJ to beat him you know and kind of
cement his legacy move on from this you
know this kind of uh it's not even it's
not bad blood it's just you know two
world-class guys going at it and each
one has a win over each other so this
this third one we don't need to see it a
fourth time so this third one kind of
cements that so
um you guys know who I'm going for so uh
I'm excited for it man the whole card's
damn good whole card is fire Rod tanks
on there if you don't know who he is
you're well if you watch this he's
probably the greatest Muay Thai artist
on the planet Mikey mucho shimmy is on
there
the uh Brazilian Jiu Jitsu technique
wise probably pound for pound number in
the world
as far as the technique goes he has
stamp vertex on there uh Sage Northcutt
coming off a long layoff his back not an
easy fight
um and then you got Roberto Sol dick
sold itch I said sold dick Soul ditch uh
the creation RoboCop so uh good fights
man really good fights our boy rdr's on
there too coming off his loss but still
this is announced bouts uh Marcus
Almeida is he really on there
I didn't see it I haven't seen anything
on it maybe he's not on there maybe
maybe they couldn't find an opponent but
yeah the whole card can be fun man I'll
be there going back to the hometown man
it's gonna be fun cool
all right what do you got to
so this was pretty popping in MMA News
Nate Diaz there's two different
incidents he was in but the guy that I
choked out is different you said there's
two different incidents so I saw online
he's sitting at the fights on for
probably a regional fight isn't it like
this was fighting okay on his fight oh
okay is there a super boxer so and I saw
the guy behind him was doing something
so then uh Nate Diaz who's just a real
sharp shooter with the water bottles uh
blasted at the dude but that's not the
same dude that he choked out right no no
but that's so the choke out came I think
it was after the event but the guy that
he threw the bottle at was his crew and
Nate Diaz's crew ended up at the same
bar so then they got into scuffle again
and that guy was part of their crew I
think he's got part of that crew yeah
they thought it was a Logan Paul like
look-alike yes that guy
what's his name Aiden
this homeboy here
well here's what Dana Aiden Ross uh so
he was with Dana White and then they're
showing a video he was like oh dude Nate
Diaz just you know slept Logan Paul but
it just looked like oh he was just
saying that uh what's interesting is um
you know I put play stupid games Win
stupid prizes and I forget someone uh
responded back to me and goes uh play
stupid game win lawsuits and he's right
like that yeah for Nate too it's like he
has so much to lose and obviously this
is Nate's
Forte you know if you disrespect Nate
you're gonna be dealt with you know he
so he doesn't care about that stuff but
the day and age we live in where he can
just Sue anybody for any reason
especially if that guy has more to lose
you know for Nate it's like I could
consume man yeah what's that guy hat
like what's Nate gonna get out of it but
also and people have said like yo Nick
professional Fighter's gonna choke this
guy out
well what's tonight supposed to do like
if that guy's approaching Nate Diaz and
Nate has hands up clearly Nate's there
you know he's gonna defend himself he
didn't throw a single punch no it's
probably best case scenario for a
homeboy you just get choked out yeah
it's embarrassing get lit up on the
Internet we're talking about it now and
we've never heard of you now the only
reason we know of you is because you got
choked out on the streets wherever this
is at that's embarrassing but you didn't
get knocked out don't get punched in the
face I think that people are saying that
in the when it was happening that when
Nate deals let go he did hit his head on
the concrete
so that sucks but I mean I'll show you
the video real quick it's not that long
[Music]
[Applause]
so the guy came up with his hands up too
yeah and then I guess now he didn't know
if he was gonna suck or punch him or
what
boy Nate gets in that tight chunk dude
clearly the guy doesn't know Jiu Jitsu
in any facet
and then just recently there's a new
angle on this one
I'll show you here
this just builds the myth of Nate Diaz
so guys are fighting so so yeah he's
already the atmosphere is very intense
clearly his team's down to fight and
then this guy comes with the Nate Nate
doesn't know if he's gonna sucker punch
him if he's gonna shoot a double you
don't know so Nate's defend himself
you don't want to get in street fights
this is silly [__] especially Nate Diaz
because again these guys can sue you
Nate has all the money in the world this
guy has nothing
yeah so that's the worst case I mean
there that's that's what you don't that
sucks yeah yeah that for him that sucks
but also
yeah don't don't mess with ideas
so that guy chased him more do you ever
watch too hot to handle it's a t uh I
know it's a dating show on Netflix that
guy chased him more is the one that Nate
threw a bottle at and he fought on that
um that event
let me see if I can find that video he's
an MMA guy no this is a boxing event but
I'll show you this real quick
so that's him in the white
so you know like somebody oh wow and he
keeps watching so he got disqualified
for that yeah I can't have that can't do
that and I don't know so anyway this guy
is like uh he's known for the too hot to
handle and I guess some some weird way
they started a beef together I don't
know why I assumed he was talking smack
to Nate yeah just for you because Nate's
not a guy that just talked smack for no
reason like there has to be something
going on there like he's not just gonna
turn around to another fight or respect
and talk [__] to just just for the
cameras that's not Nate yeah the ball
also the water ball thing I didn't
really understand it just I didn't see
anything happen the video just shows
Nate hitting around then yeah throwing a
water ball maybe the guy kept talking
maybe yeah I don't know yeah either way
but uh it's just interesting and it's
been getting all this attention
especially after you know just the
announcement of the Jake Paul stuff too
yeah
uh this is a quick a quick one I don't
need to play the video but Conor
McGregor went to this I saw the video
yeah that's great that's what you want
to hear yeah if you're Ryan Garcia and
you know say what you want about Conor
he's been some of the biggest fights
ever in Combat Sports like for him to
come in be like you're the future I just
want to see it again yeah and because
and one of the problems that the Box
Community has because of guys MMA has it
a little bit because of guys like Floyd
Mayweather who's whatever 50-0 or uh you
know Tyson Fury in their undefeated
records and then MMA of Jon Jones that's
that's not really how the sport should
go so in boxing it's all good Ryan loss
at his young age Canelo lost to Floyd
Mayweather at a young age turned out
pretty good for him he's had a Hall of
Fame career so I think once the fan base
gets more knowledge it goes yeah a guy
loses comes back you know it's all good
a loss does not end your career doesn't
make or break your career now his next
fight he needs to show out and perform
but that's usually how it should go so I
think people lose lose in Translation
where they're like well Floyd was on Jon
Jones on defeated it's like yes those
guys are such out they're once in a
lifetime Talent generational Talent it's
okay if a guy loses it's all especially
when they're young it's all good it's
all good and I guess he's changing
weight classes too after yes to 140 yeah
all right this is a quick one so there
was a Bellator over the weekend and uh I
believe
kyoji horguchi xuf UCI badass Japanese
dude and uh Ray board we're supposed to
fight each other I think that was like
the main event too but then oh no no
wasn't me not no it wasn't that I forgot
at least on Saturday because in Hawaii
too right
starts was the main event we got he got
uh homeboy knocked him out with a knee
um okay so yeah I don't I didn't look
too much in this but then so this is
like I read it was like the 17th time
there was a cancellation not just wait
but just cancellation that has to do
with Ray Borg yeah so Bellator cut them
cut him and also his management team and
then Ray said he just retired yeah he
said if it were to happen again he's
gonna dip out it's been good for him and
also remember Ray board has an issue
so for don't hold it against him too
much when he misses Wade or whatever I
know it's unprofessional but he's
fighting a much bigger fight outside the
Octagon hmm
alrighty let's go to so
Paula Costa was saying that he's gonna
help save the UFC 288 card with uh
challenging Jan blockovich he would go
up to 208 205. and then apparently
John's saying that he actually got
offered the fight but then Paulo turned
it down well because Paulo they're out
from Hamza so he's like all right that's
a bigger fight
I mean there's more I don't know so a
few days ago uh Paulo Caso got offered
to fight me I've saved yes he said no
the fight is off how much juice does he
need one bottle of wine is enough to
knock this guy out
yeah and he's a social media dude that
likes to do stuff so I don't know what
the hell is going on yep and then also
from the business aspect of things too
for Apollo Costa like so we'll give you
if you want to do yawn at 205 you can do
that or we'll give you hamzat but you
gotta take one of the two and he's like
well Hans that's a bigger fight and it's
at 85 I'll take that
and this is another quick one Floyd
Mayweather he was talking about angano
being you know free agent and he would
like to sign him and work with him as
well that'd be great yeah we need
something out of Francis you know
and then so you mentioned all the about
announcements
so this is one that was big Robert
Whittaker versus drukas duplessis
that's for UFC 290. uh listen I'm gonna
do a policies fan I do I do enjoy his
fights I think he's a complete badass uh
actually that guy in one Championship
that uh croatians got beat him you know
so that that's how much of a badass that
guys but who knows if he only had eight
percent to breathe there but uh do
policies I just don't see how he beats
Robert Whittaker I don't know what the
odds are but it can't be good that's
such a tough fight Robert Whittaker
beats everybody except not named Izzy
he's that guy he's so [__] talented
so this is what dreika suplexes put on
his uh I think this Twitter whatever and
then Israel replied please win yeah for
Izzy he much rather fight to please see
something new instead of a third fight
if he beats Robert then if you be
flowering he completely deserves it yeah
I just don't see it happening I just and
it's not I'm not throwing shade on
duplicates that's how high I think of
Robert Whittaker yeah
so that's cool how that plays out this
is also pretty cool Robbie Lawler versus
Nico price and Dan hooker versus Jalen
Turner hooker Jalen Turner is ridiculous
yeah they're both great fights yeah
and then on top of that
uh Sean Brady versus Jack Dylan and Jack
has been killing it too oh Jack that boy
got so much talent yeah boy that boy
Sean Brady man they heavy lies the crown
man you know you're coming off that loss
against Muhammad didn't give you jack I
know that's a tough stay in the office
you guys know I love Sean Brady but that
Jack
man he's a problem rising star for sure
um this is for ESC 289 keto George sent
this to our group Chris stalkus who's a
heavyweight doctor's cutting down yep
two yeah you could cut a few pounds he's
gonna fight Khalil Roundtree in front of
the show
the Philly cop cutting some weight
laying off the donuts in Philly and the
cheesecake cheesesteaks and so Chris is
actually dacus he's not gonna three
fight losing streak and then khalil's on
a three fight winning streak but it was
a different weight class though you're
tough tough fight for Chris
and this one too this is a Fight Night
headliner which is crazy so Marvin
vittori versus Jared cannonier that
makes sense either headline on a fight
night or been on like a second or third
fight in a pay-per-view makes sense
especially how high these guys ranked
it's just they gotta figure out
middleweight there's not a lot frizzy
there that's why you're getting Robert
Whittaker you're getting the homs up
Paulo Costa again Marvel inventory you
know and uh Jared Canon there they're
trying to you know cut through all the
the fat there and get some contenders
for Izzy
and then we have I mean we kind of knew
this already but Charles Oliver vanilla
Darius they're rebooked for 289 289. man
usually they bring the heat in Canada
but this card is not great
is it
like no one was like I'm just dying to
see Pena and Amanda Nunez three yeah
especially after the last one
it's a tough card to ask for money for
yeah I mean if if Darius and Charles
Oliveira didn't save this thing dude I
don't know how you sell this it's tough
very very tough by the way pay-per-view
the freaking Ryan Garcia fight costs
84.99 I think it's 89.99 it was like you
know I didn't realize it was that
expensive I was like but I still bought
it damn right you did
yeah okay this is getting to like a
different area territory but uh-oh I saw
this passing I saw this on social media
uh Israel lasagna is making posts about
his ex-girlfriend why something about
how he doesn't go super clear into it
but he's kind of insinuating that she's
trying to get half of his money what I
don't know and then his girlfriend I
know it's not even a wife or not even
yeah a mother of his child or anything
as far as I know but apparently she's
trying to get some sort of money and
he's putting her on blast on his own oh
no yeah it's never good when you do that
um that's what he said here you don't
care about my life because you've sold
info about me so I don't care about
yours I don't even I don't even hate I
just don't care about you I've I've not
been in love with you for a while in
summary I'm glad this happened I
wouldn't change a [__] thing he's
like slapping this on his on his like
Instagram so I mean
I don't know do you know that the story
about the soccer player how he had yes
yeah he changed he put everything in his
mother's name she came for it he's like
I don't know yeah so he he reposted
something about man Hall of Fame right
there
yeah
but what did she say what is she
alluding to like what what info did did
she really I mean all he's saying all we
know is what he's saying and he said
that I guess he
she sold some sort of info about him
but he says like you better lawyer up
you better do this I'm gonna go after
you oh wow go down
me loading up her seats
and there's a lot forever stylebenders X
let me see that
wait let me see if I can get it
all right let's just see if I can zoom
in here can you read that
um is that that's her ex that's the
thing that I don't I don't get so he
puts it in quotations so I think that
he's saying that's her
okay
so this is apparently her thing I worked
on or I've worked in mental health so
I'm really good at manipulating people
but like I would never use it it's not
always fun living in his shadow and
talking or taking second priority
because what he's doing is so important
after a while it just makes me feel
small and then Izzy if I move out I'll
drift away and it seems like this is
where Izzy's talking to her
which is very long
he says you have a sugar daddy now that
would pay for it all
[Music]
I mean super long I don't know how
mentally drained me ha ha ha
but it seems like if you mess with Izzy
he takes it out like hardcore he'll put
it out in public
so this is the last time you're hearing
from me my lawyers will be in touch and
did the Emoji on the main Nails yeah
you know comes the territory for these
guys yeah and then uh he posted this as
well
well I don't know if I can play this
because this song I think
oh no
[Music]
Rich you know he's playing Charlemagne
that is Rich that is in a position
they really love they really love that
this [__] don't give a [__] and
he's in the position where he should
actually give the [__] both you know
what I mean regular man and they they
look they love a rebel that actually has
something that's why we love when people
become like big time celebrities and
they still act like regular and still
you know say suck my dick in an award
show get on TV and say George Bush don't
care about black people right you know
yeah as he's doing this yeah and he he
also made some headlines because he said
something about you know men are getting
soft and she said you know what Andrew
Taylor Jordan Peterson is like the way
yeah yeah something like that yeah I
mean I have a problem with it neither do
I was saying he's right yeah America's
getting soft this is so jacked up so
this guy was a UFC fighter called
Roberson
and let me see if I have this okay
nevermind so call Robertson he was a UFC
for a while I think he won a contender
series and did like pretty well
but I guess he's going through some bad
times now so in December of 2022 he
robbed
his one of his childhood friends house
for two hundred thousand dollars worth
of jewelry Jesus Christ yeah and then
the dude even told him like he
at home let's see here
so this guy is talking about Carl
Robertson he goes before I had to dive
into my name I could barely afford this
but I made a pair of boxing gloves with
my logo on it
there's my first sample and I made him a
pair of gloves with his nickname on it
Baby K he goes hey man this is from me
to you I don't want anything for this
this is just something I want you to
have I'm proud of you I did whatever
records of supporting and lo and behold
the day after Christmas he basically
lined me up I guess he gave him like
thousands of dollars
yeah it's a bummer
I built a whole logo for him brand it
gave him tens of thousand dollars with
my time to build a brand he basically
screwed me over that too it's not the
same kid I grew up with it's not the
same kid in those pictures I had no idea
Carl has this other side
he would like text him because he was
talking to yeah trust me he's building
his house yeah he was sending hey what
do you think of this and then because of
that the whole all the like he gave him
the diagram the dude knew how to get to
where the jewelry was and stuff like
it's so [__] up yeah people suck man
yeah trust me I've been some people are
people dude yeah you think they're good
people and they're just the worst of the
worst people are good actors
and he must be going I don't know it's
not no excuse for it even if you're
going through [__] all right so this did
you know this I saw Tim Sylvia Tim
Sylvia 370 something life out of
something dude he's he's so thick yeah
this is Debut I guess he was a headline
poor soul decided to sign up for this
[Applause]
[Music]
he's so big two Skechers on my God
but I mean slap the life who the hell is
signed up to get slapped by Tim Sylvia
let me see that angle
that was a bouncer he's a bouncer
oh that's his nickname
but I'm not so sure
Wanna Know
I mean
yeah I don't know who signed up get
slapped by that giant human being
is that a chin that's pretty much it man
all right man well let's get into a
little sit down with my boy blalel
Mohammed who has a massive fight coming
up in two weeks May 6 against Gilbert
Burns
before we jump into this little chitch
out the boy blue Mohammed who is on a
freaking Vengeance path to a title shot
this episode of the shop show with Balia
Muhammad is brought to you by on it on
its supplements
let me tell you something about on it
they've been my ride or die for a long
long time and they've sold over a
million dollar million bottles of Alpha
Brain a million bottles of that regular
Alpha Brain and I start out with that
and then you gotta step your game up
that's why I recommend Alpha Brain Black
Label four little pills you're ready to
go next you know you're writing
formulations you're a scientists you
feel fantastic promotes attention focus
cognitive functions including your
memory mental speed and focus I I need
all the help I can get for God's sakes
AIDS and mental processing it's caffeine
free helps you get to that flow State
all right and also what on it's doing
for you guys if you don't like the pills
they have their uh little on it Alpha
Brain instant eight ounces of cold water
boom you ready to go or they have the
instant ready shots the Boom the shots
are easy as well all right again it's
going to help you just get your freaking
stuff done man and he gives you laser
focus on it also offers if you didn't
know workout gear like kettlebell steel
Club maces sandbags yoga mats if you
need nutrition if you're staying thick
summer's coming up it's gonna be a thick
Boy Summer it's not out of shape Boy
Summer it's a thick boy summer so we can
stay thick but be cool all right on it
has all sorts of protein powders
creatines multivitamins they got it oh
man all right they have streaming
Fitness so you can keep your thick ass
at home and work out from your device at
home in your garage in your living room
whatever you want they got it all on
it.com shop you get temp shop Alpha
Brain Black regular Alpha Brain Alpha
Brain instant Alpha Brain shots all the
workout gear the kettlebells also on
demand workouts you get temps off
everything on it.com shop now let's get
to the interview Mr Muhammad what's up
brother
uh what's up my brother how you doing
good man how are you you got to be
feeling pretty good man finally finally
you got a fight announce man
yeah man excited I was sitting there
waiting when it was gonna happen and it
was like just dragging and dragging
along now I'm a guy that's I'm always
training I'm always like looking to see
what's next and obviously once they pass
me up on a title fight I'm like all
right well who's it gonna be like who's
gonna be next and uh when this
opportunity came I was like bro I gotta
jump on it could you I'm sure you know
you're pretty active on social media
could you feel like the majority of the
hardcore fan base or anybody that kind
of knows the sport all of us were like
what Muhammad like what are we doing
here like there's so many people
advocating for you to get a fight
calling for a title shot like could you
feel that or did you know that was going
on
yeah that was the cool thing about the
whole situation it was like them giving
the shot to Kobe I think it like worked
out better for me because that's when
the fans started to be like all right
well bro that doesn't make any sense at
all this guy's on 85 winning streak he
has history with Leon you know what else
does he need to do so it's cool to see
those fans even the haters that were
coming alive I was like getting so many
messages like I hate you but
yeah it's undeniable it's like
undeniable like when you look at your
resume look at Gilbert Burns resume you
know and then when they said they're
going to give it to Colby it's just like
and you know I like Kobe you know to be
transparent like I like Kobe I have an
issue with him he's a good he's a really
good fighter but if you just it's pretty
black and white like well look at little
Muhammad's look at Gilbert burns like
look at their resumes and he's had this
year off it just it just doesn't make a
ton of sense to me you know Dana can run
it however he wants but what's fair is
fair you know there's rankings for a
reason even though he's ranked High
still it's like the guys who are active
I figured they'd give it to you now it's
undeniable winner of you versus Gilbert
Burns is 100 getting the title shot
yeah exactly for me it was like I knew
there was nothing that was just going to
be handed to me I knew that no matter
what it was there was always going to be
me still having a claw and you know get
to the top any way possible and even
when I got to the top I was still gonna
have to hold my breath because
regardless of how I finished my last
fight or who I beat there's always an
excuse of oh you beat this guy because
of this this guy because of this John
Brady 15-0 undefeated young guy Beast oh
he sucks he's not that good and there
was always like a reason and like
excuses for everything so for this one
it's like when this opportunity popped
up it was like all right well Gilbert
burn has the hype he'd just be Mazda
he'd just be magnet he's coming off a
camp I'm coming off the couch at the
Ramadan I'm like beating him now there's
no excuse there's no excuse they could
go against me now it's like I'm the one
who just popped up and I was like all
right well let me fight the guy that
just came off the camp a guy that's
already close to wait uh a guy that's
just one and has the momentum going in
his way
um and I go out there I finished him I
dominate him
there's there's literally nothing you
can say or do to deny me nothing nothing
when that was my question too when the
fight got announced uh you know I knew
you're in Ramadan which you know is a
month long right just ended on April
21st have you been able to train during
that like that has to be challenging
that's why I thought all right the
fight's in two weeks come off Ramadan so
is it ideal are you all good like what's
the what's going on with it I mean for
me it's like I'm always in the gym
you're obviously not training as hard
but I think the the biggest thing I get
from Ramadan is like the mental strength
my mental toughness that I get from it
is not eating or drinking throughout the
day and I'm still training and pushing
myself I'm just in a different headspace
and a lot of these times when it comes
to a short notice fight it's not even
about being in a shape it's about what
type of headspace you're in what type of
mindset you're in because when it comes
down to the nitty-gritty it's all about
who can push that much harder and who
has the bigger heart who has the the
harder mindset and I know that yeah with
the where I'm at right now my headspace
I'll fight to fight like I don't care if
I didn't jog enough miles I don't care
if I didn't swim enough laps
I know when it comes down to who's gonna
push harder than other guy there ain't
nobody that's gonna push harder than me
yeah and you've been doing it long
enough now where you know you know what
it takes to to get the win in there you
look at your resume yeah and with with
the Gilbert Burns fight when it was
announced too I you know and not that
odds matter when I thought for sure
you'd be a slight favorite going in the
fight when I look at the the the matchup
and the style of the matchup I was like
man that's a great fight for Muhammad
man like he's gonna be able to do some
work there I was surprised you're a dog
which all right cool that's all good but
when you heard the matchup you have to
like the match-up between you and
Gilbert Burns even though he's been
active coming off some wins I didn't
think Gilbert looked his best against
mozvanol I love Gilbert's a great guy I
don't know if you know Gilbert you know
salt of the earth great human being but
just as far as a straight black and
white take my bias out of it watching
the Mazel doll fight I I didn't think he
looked his best in that fight
yeah you know he he's very cool like I
met him before we've talked like a lot
of the same friends and I've gone down
to Sanford and I've trained on they're
not really not with him but like I'm
very cool with his coach any group is
the man so like when the situation came
up it's like I don't need to hate
somebody to fight him it's all about
we're both hungry for the same thing
we're both want the same exact
goal and that's to be the champion and I
think that you know match up stylistic
wise like I fought the best Grappler in
the division with Damian Maya I thought
the best striker in the division with
Wonder Boy I fought the the guy who
knocked me out and his training partner
and Luca and I beat Luke and I thought
the the new up-and-coming hot star
strongest guy in the division and Sean
Brady I thought every single style and I
don't think Gilbert's fought anybody
like me I don't think Gilbert's fought
anybody that's gonna push it like me
move like me uh adjust like me make
in-fight adjustments like you see me
fight backwards you see me fight forward
you see me fight laterally he doesn't
know what I'm gonna bring to the table I
know what he's gonna bring to the table
because I've been watching him and he
doesn't really change his game plan or
her style up and this being a short
notice fight there's not a lot of
strategy that comes in it from from his
side it's like well I'm gonna do this
because I'm good at it but I'm better at
it you're good at I also think your your
last one over Sean Brady actually helps
you in this fight you know because you
we just saw Brady's grappling background
like Sean Brady's no punk man you made
it look easy and people must have forgot
but prior to that prior to you beating
the brakes off of them chambray is a bad
dude man and you dismantle him like you
did it it was almost a disservice to
your win and DeSean Brady to be like oh
Sean Brady's not that good it's like no
he is that's how good Muhammad is you
morons like Brady still has a lot of he
like obviously has a lot of work to do
but as far as stylists getting compared
to Gilbert Burns he didn't have the same
striking Gilbert does but on the ground
and the grab as far as the grappling
aspect goes I think that was kind of a
good fight leading into the Gilbert
Burns fight
yeah I think I said I think he was a
perfect stylistic he has kind of like
the same body type yeah and I know what
they're they're both going to try to
bring to the table and like you said man
I'm sitting here like man I hope Sean
Brady gets a fight in so he could go out
there Dominate and then people could be
like oh well I guess he is good he
doesn't suck uh because now it's like
you're like oh well if ballon knocked
you out man you must really suck your
stand-up sucks I don't get out there he
dominates his next guy uh then people
are like all right same thing with
Wonder Boy it was like Wonder Boys old
then he goes out there beats Kevin
Holland and it's like oh well I guess
Wonder Boy isn't old I guess he still
has a little bit juice left in him so
it's you always want the last guy you
beat to end up winning but like you said
it's like same body type same style same
physique there him and Gilbert have a
lot of similarities
um so it does work out kind of like for
me a lot because I'm kind of like gonna
really do
basically the same thing in my mind uh
what I did to Sean Brady to Gilbert yeah
and I think just the Stars aligned for
you you know with this Gilbert Burns
fight because again whatever the
naysayers are saying about oh you know
Wonder Boys old or Sean Brady's you know
he's young he's not that good after
Gilbert burns like what else you got man
what else we got guys fought four times
you know he's fought three times this
year since May he's beat everybody what
else you got man you know yeah and
exactly Gilbert Burns will be my third
top five guy that I've beaten and it's
like by the time I get to the title I'm
already gonna be beating probably like
the whole top ten yeah I was like oh man
he's gonna be going through the division
uh one more time again another laugh
through it but I'm basically gonna be
looking at a science because
I've gone through everybody just to get
to the about to make title yeah you know
I I think with this fight the the
biggest problem you're gonna have if the
fight goes to Corn how I think he's in
go and how you think it's gonna go if if
you get past Gilbert burns your next
issue it's gonna be a good problem to
have is Jim be waiting a while to fight
the winner of Leon versus Cole because
you know Leon's not fighting in the
London pay-per-view card he's like I'm
not fine so he's fighting you know
probably quarter three quarter four of
this year and so then you'd have fight
the winner of that so you're looking at
early 2024 Maybe
yeah I mean but honestly if Leon's
saying he wants to fight an Abu Dhabi
and he's he said Abu Dhabi it coming out
of his mouth and he said I don't want to
fight Kobe yeah and he's and I go out
there and I finish Gilbert Burns it's
like you have to put me in Abu Dhabi
against Leonards the time will be
perfect Leon wants to fight there having
me fight there in Arab fighting in Abu
Dhabi for a title it's different I know
Islam fighting there is huge she's been
being Muslim but we speak the same
language we have the same blood inside
of us uh for to have an Arab fight in
Abu Dhabi in front of his people would
be bigger than anything you could do I
also think it puts the pressure on Dana
White I know he's pretty you know
steadfast on Kobe Covington getting this
title shot but if you go out there and
you make a convincing
you know push and you you finish Gilbert
Burns which is damn hard to do and you
beat Gilbert and you give him a freaking
promo towards Elon Edwards UFC's Mike
all right man all right there's nothing
he's done everything there's nothing
else you can't hold this guy back any
longer
exactly and that like I said stuff
always changes in this Sport and you
know Dana White could say whatever he
wants but like he's a businessman he
understands the business of it if I go
out there and I put on that big thing
there is history between me and land
there is no history between Kobe and
Leon there's nothing that's gonna be a
good build up to that fight you go there
or you go man this guy fought two week
notice right after Ramadan now he's
fighting the guy that poked him in the
eye and like there's stuffed in there
there's there's something there with
that fight and there's something that
you could build off of that fight and
it'll be a huge moment and for the UFC
they'll get a lot more respect from the
fans I think to get somebody that
deserves it more than Kobe you know what
the other the biggest thing is that
you're missing bill it's the right thing
to do
you know what I'm saying like that come
on yeah like at the end of the day it is
a sport you know what I'm saying at the
end of the day it is a professional
sport like it's the right thing to do
you know yeah as much as the Kobe and
all that and Kobe does bring a fan base
but is this is the right thing to do man
yeah I was just watching the uh the
Michael Jordan movie The Air the air
yesterday oh how was it with Ben Affleck
it was really good it was really good it
was cool and it was like kind of like
how Michael Jordan's mom like wanted uh
she's the one who wanted the percentage
of every shoe that had Michael Jordan's
name on there and you know Nike they
never did it before but he's like you
know it's the right thing to do whatever
I let's do it we're gonna change the
game but we're gonna do it and then it
like changed everything and it changed
his life and it changed the way that
Sports in general uh you know may choose
for our athletes yeah I think I think
for you too it's like you have the
hardcores and the UFC fan base on your
side and everyone wants to you get the
tile shot because you deserve it I think
you know if if you were to come world
champion too once people get to know you
and they see your story like there's a
star there there's a [__] if they
just put a little shine on this thing
man we got a diamond here and I'm not
even say diamond the rough it's not that
rough like you you proved yourself you
know what I'm saying it's like as soon
as the light goes over there boom it's
gangbusters for you brother yeah I mean
I tell people all the time I'm sitting
there like bro I'm promoting myself I'm
pushing myself let me get a little bit
of something out of the UFC and more
people will see it more people will
realize oh dang you know he's a cool guy
I get it all the time people like oh man
I hated you for some reason but man I
don't know why and it's like you don't
know me so like a lot of people just go
with the the losers or the trolls on
Twitter and they'll think that it's a
certain way because of that but then
when you're meeting in person or you
hear my story more you're like oh dang
this is just a regular guy that works
twice as hard everybody else's ass off
yeah yeah I'm not a guy that has uh
Francis got you power or the the crazy
Alexandria movement I haven't been doing
martial arts since I was a kid I've been
I started when I was 22 23 years old and
I just worked twice as hard as everybody
else yeah your time's coming my man you
know it's coming bro it's just that's
all you can do is be patient it's coming
and you're doing it the right way uh
before this Gilbert Burns fight there
was a lot of rumors that you're gonna
fight was it uh caught right
don't believe everything you read on the
internet so I was like maybe it's not
happening because that made no sense to
me I was like yo to do my boy dirty that
makes no sense
yeah yeah for me it was like that it
there's nothing ever a fight ever
offered with uh shopkat and it was like
Dana mentioned it once an interview but
then like we had our meeting and after
the meeting we thought we were gonna
fight kamaru
um and for me it was like tomorrow's
ranked number one in the division he's a
ex-champion and you know I even talked
with Camaro and he's like yeah yeah we
could do it so like I thought that was
gonna be the fight and it was like it
was probably gonna happen in July August
so there was really no timetable on it
uh it was still waiting on him to figure
it out so then when I had this
opportunity it was like
I could skip all that because I could
sit there go through a full eight week
12 week Camp to fight tomorrow and
there's nothing guaranteed I can still
go out there get caught with one punch
and get dropped and you know the first
minute so for me it's like when
Opportunity Knocks in it's a big
opportunity like this on a pay-per-view
to be a coal main event and then knowing
that I beat Gilbert Burns there's
nothing else ahead of me uh I had to
take it no I I love it man and when you
look at uh obviously Kobe was in the
news because he threatened our boy John
annik which you got you know what Kobe's
thing you know he does the WWE thing
where he pushes the line pushes the line
then you know not similar to Kanye but
Kanye is always pushing the envelope and
then you cross the line we went for Jews
Kobe cross line went for John anik he
doesn't realize how beloved John hammock
is and that's where people are like oh
hell no that's when he realized he
crossed the line you know what I'm
saying so I think with with Kobe doing
that you know it it almost helps you
it's like the you know you're the good
guy you're the superhero here and he you
know he's the villain so even if Kobe
were to beat Leon there's a great story
there of Good Guy versus bad guy
yeah exactly and especially with with
that one like I've been calling out the
Kobe fight for for years even before it
was uh cool to call out Kobe I was
telling them out where it was like my
second or third fight in the UFC because
from then I wanted to just I like the
style matchup and I you know I wanted to
test myself now I just hate him and it's
just like like you said the the stupid
stuff he says is just moronic and now
like that you cross the line you know
you thought it would be cool you thought
it would be good but no you don't come
at John Annie's not the guy you come at
no you got two guys yeah you don't cover
you don't come after Rogan or anec them
the rules yeah Dana Dana he'll take his
you know he'll take his uh [__] enough
of it because he encourages it but
Anakin Rogan off limits dude you just
can't you just can't get away with it
you know
um I'll get you at it after this but
because I know you're gonna get some
more training and I don't keep you too
long man but um when if Colby and Leon
uh does come to fruition you have to
wait how do you see Kobe and Leon going
down
I see uh you know kind of like a little
bit like the second fight with Usman I
think he showed a kind of like a game
plan to beat Leon is pushing him to
defense taking him down he gets up keep
taking him down keep pressuring him I
think the third fight Usman just wasn't
you know all there I I think he was a
little bit hesitant off of that knockout
and even though it was still a close
fight I still just think that his
confidence wasn't there with his
wrestling is entering uh he was thinking
about the hecky too long Colby he's just
gonna be in your face shoot on you 50
times
um but he's not as good as USANA holding
you down I think eventually Leon will
end up catching him and I do think that
Leon can't finish him if it's not a
finish by Leon it'll definitely be a
decision by Kobe yeah I tend to agree
with that I think you're looking at the
cross when Leon the last fight their
third fight I thought it was a matter of
yeah Kamara being a little gun shy there
but also I think Leon Edwards has gotten
better exceptionally better since the
first time they fought I think uh Leon
has gotten better even more so over the
years than Colby has so I think Leon's
getting better gaining some tools and
these other guys are kind of staying the
same and getting a little older but Leon
keeps getting better and he's he's kind
of you know why in The Gap there
yeah and he's sharpening everything else
he said he's he's getting more tools
Kobe he's sticking to what he knows and
the level of competition Kobe his last
fight was against Mexico the last guy he
did before that was like uh you know
Robbie Lawler those aren't like guys
that are as hungry because these up and
comers that are every one of these guys
is starving like Kobe's not fighting
guys that are starving yeah he had close
fights with Usman but it was just two
wrestlers that were kickboxing and it
was there's not much there so you knew
what you were gonna get from those
fights he's not sharpening he's not
getting better he's not bringing
something new to the table Leon his
Russian defense getting better he's
switching stances he's going he's
showing you that you know he does have
that knockout power in the fifth round
so I could see him still being hungry
Kobe's not doesn't have that same hunger
I think he's he knows what's what wins
and fights and he's just trying to keep
sharpening those tools up but now we've
come to expect what we're gonna get from
well no one can argue you got the
probably the toughest strength of
schedule out there man that deserves the
title shot you got that sec football
Alabama schedule man you know what I'm
saying like it is murders bro uh I'm I'm
happy you got this fight man uh you know
how I'm rooting for brother and I
appreciate you taking the time and I
can't wait to see it man and we're doing
a fight campaign for it we got Ryan
Garcia some other big names we're all
gonna be rooting for you man so best of
luck brother stay healthy and Camp do
the damn thing and we'll talk to you
after appreciate you man thank you man
all right brother talk soon all right
kids hope you all enjoyed the show with
Berlin Muhammad just breaking down his
big ass fight May 6 for the big UFC
pay-per-view we will be doing a fight
campaign for that cow bass fight Command
right here live from thick boy Studios
to watch Muhammad get the damn thing
done we have a very special guest and
Ryan Garcia joining the campaign and two
other monsters all announced coming up
shortly here so tune into that that will
be 7 P.M live on thick boy YouTube May 6
for the big UFC pay-per-view uh outside
that like subscribe we'll be blasting a
bunch more content hopefully you all dig
it
um as far as torn goes May I'll be doing
spots around La and we have the fight
companion but next date as far as the
tour goes is La Jolla California La
Jolla comedy store right outside San
Diego uh two shows on Friday two shows
on Saturday and then one show on a
Sunday so that is Friday Saturday Sunday
June 2nd through June 4th at the comedy
store in La Jolla so come get you some
and then I'm jumping across the pond in
June for the summer I'm in Europe I'm in
Belfast I kick off with Belfast uh
that's June 15th these are one show only
at the theater run so one show in
Belfast one show in Glasgow June 17th
once you in Manchester I think uh yeah
Manchester that's June 18th London O2
theater June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd
Dublin my favorite I've ever been to
June 25th get your tickets now at
thickboy.com that's it kids love you see
you next time I'm out
the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
[Music]
Johnson versus Marias 3 on Prime video